so some of you guys might know that my
birthday is on March 20th and there's
also a very very very exciting game that
is coming out on March 20th see of these
Jen and I had so much fun we're playing
the beta and every time I would leave to
go get a snack or walk the dog I would
come back I would be in the brig and the
ship would be full of water and I'd be
drowning playing my freakin accordion
waiting for my friends and nobody would
let me out but all of that aside I am
freaking out right now because behind me
Microsoft and rare surprised me with a
birthday cake and I am absolutely
freaking out and Jenna was the secret
ingredient to making it all happen I was
a party planner I helped out no not
decorating it just planning planning I'm
very excited because I think it turned
out just how I imagined it looks really
good
I have only peeked very very quickly
inside of it and I'm freaking out so I'm
gonna do an unboxing of my birthday cake
right is this the first unboxing you a
birthday cake what's this a memory
Boxster cake before nope what Michael is
[Music]
delicious tarts made this cake and they
are so talented like I'm actually in
shock oh I can't even believe this so
the instructions they gave me were to
cut here did they tell you that did they
tell me that's what they said right
where's there this inside I'm not sure
oh gosh well let's just find out the
problem is this knife is actually not
better did you cut the cake what if you
cut the
I can't wait for you guys to see this
you're gonna be in shock Wow
hold up hold up this is these act
from the game this is the exception
there's the month we can drink the beers
there's a little treasure chest and
there's me
it's a bread that is meals like that's
not a character in the game but it
should be lipstick and it looks really
good on me I should I should think about
it
happy birthday I just seen do you guys
get it aye matey I would also just like
to say that normally they said that they
needed six to eight weeks and I gave
them less than a week they did an
awesome job like the ship I think it
really is what's not edible on here
there was a few things that weren't
edible I have to read it no more things
it eliris I think this is trouble with
not edible that looks like a piece of
wood the bananas oh this is all Rice
Krispies and chocolate and fondant and
then this is
cake Thank You Jonah thank you Microsoft
thank you rare
you better believe you're gonna be
finding me out on the high seas what are
you doing in here
hey so 100 thieves were in the playoff
hunt and so we need a couple of teams to
lose or win today so I'm watching the
magic this is all about see if it's
today buddy
thank you now it's time to get some
slow-mo close-up shots of this thing it
looks so amazing
[Music]
oh wow they're real pirates are the ones
that play Disney really James they're
like professional darlin there are so
many dogs here and it's kind of crazy
because now we all have dogs there we
got all of us have dogs now last the day
after we all got up we had lunch and
classes like I can never get a dog later
dog under 20 things long and they go
yeah whatever you like what happens you
have to pray with when you get your
shirts mommy I'm scared right now oh my
gosh you're falling over Matt you're
heavy little boy you will never be like
them
[Applause]
[Music]
this is great my love scene you are
extra
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies
[Music]
this is awesome
10,000 miles away
today happy birthday to me
[Applause]
okay it's your show okay yeah oh it's
listing Justin so it's coming down
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm at the break oh my god guys like
Pocky okay I'm gonna get it I'm wearing
on us are wearing light lipstick no this
is really good
never look better I'll take that title
wheeler it's several
maybe just one yeah we just get a quick
burn it's not edible it's edible yeah
it's all fuel there's a lot of
commentary I gotta get over here
don't eat that so this looks cool oh
it's gonna smell like toasted
marshmallows I guess this is a good time
I like burning fire
we said no I don't want to leave a
little bit yeah I'm a real quick let's
take a look what's inside here oh yeah
so Susie got me this is amazing so she
also got me this drone
this is a balloon Jerome balloon animals
new nano drone balloon look at its
tongue it's so cool and then she also
got me this this is a pineapple and
inside of it instead of can because I
was like uh I gotta stop eating so much
candy friends Telecom you know I think
it is I think it's the friends food
truck why would a food truck have four
bellies oh I know what it is
it's the pickup ride home
[Music]